vamos a resolver la desigualdad el valor
absoluto de 12 r menos 3 enteros un
cuarto esto tiene que ser menor que 2
enteros un medio y bueno de hecho antes
de meterme a resolver esta desigualdad
con valor absoluto quiero recordar un
poco lo que veíamos en el vídeo pasado
si yo tenía que el valor absoluto de x
era menor que pues dos enteros un medio
vamos a tomarnos lo mismo que quiere
decir esto
bueno que x tenía que ser menor que dos
enteros un medio x tiene que ser menor
que dos enteros un medio y a su vez x
tiene que ser mayor que menos dos
enteros un medio tiene que ser mayor que
menos dos enteros un medio ambas
desigualdades se tienen que cumplir
simultáneamente y si esto lo veíamos una
recta numérica ya que estaba el cero
aquí estaba el dos enteros un medio y
por aquí el menos dos enteros un medio
si yo me fijo en la distancia que hay
del 0 al 2 enteros un medio y al menos
dos enteros un medio pues vamos a ver
que hay dos unidades y media de
distancia al cero y si yo lo que quiero
es buscar los números que cumplan que su
distancia sea menor que dos enteros un
medio pues tiene que ser aquellos
que están entre estos dos valores es
decir todos estos la distancia de este
número al cero tiene que ser menor que
dos enteros un medio por lo tanto tiene
que ser todo esto que estoy pintando de
azul justo esto era lo que habíamos
visto hace algunos vídeos y más aún si
nosotros tendríamos que el valor
absoluto de x era mayor que dos enteros
un medio lo que nos resultaba de
solución era justo lo contrario los
intervalos que eran más grandes que dos
enteros un medio o en dado caso más
chicos que menos dos enteros un medio
pero bueno regresemos a este problema
original yo lo que quiero es que esto
esto que está adentro de mi valor
absoluto va a servir igual que x es
decir lo que quiero es que 12 r menos
tres enteros un cuarto sea menor que dos
enteros un medio que dos enteros medio y
a su vez simultáneamente se cumpla que
dos r menos tres enteros un cuarto sea
más grande que menos dos enteros un
medio estoy utilizando exactamente la
misma lógica que utilicé aquí la derecha
es más déjenme hacer una línea para que
no nos confundamos esto que está dentro
de mi valor absoluto es justo lo que yo
me refiere con la x aquí del lado
derecho y bueno si ya te
las desigualdades lo único que hay que
hacer es resolverlas para él y por lo
tanto lo único que hay que hacer es
despejar a r pero si te das cuenta que
tenemos fracciones así que lo primero
que voy a hacer es pasar estas
fracciones de mixtas a impropias y para
esto lo que ves es multiplicar 4 por 3
12 + 1 lo bueno es que lo que haga de un
lado también me va a servir del otro
lado o al menos en un principio y
entonces mejor voy a escribir esto como
2 r menos 4 por 3 12 13 sep son tres
cuartos entonces va a quedar 12 r menos
13 cuartos esto tiene que ser menor o
igual esperar cuartos no tercios no me
va a ello confundir por una cosita si
esto tiene que ser menor que 2 por 24 15
es decir cinco medios bueno esto por una
parte pero por otra parte también
tenemos que dos ere menos tres enteros
un cuarto tiene que ser mayor que menos
dos enteros un medio pero bueno esto es
lo mismo que dos r menos trece cuartos
tiene que ser mayor que menos cinco
medios muy bien pero como no es lo mejor
trabajar con fracciones a mí lo que se
me ocurre es multiplicar toda esta
desigualdad por cuatro como el 40
se mantiene la desigualdad y entonces
vamos a multiplicar todo esto por 4 y
que me va a quedar 4 por 12 384 que
multiplica menos 13 cuartos pues el 4 y
el 4 se van y me queda menos 13 y
después date cuenta que la desigualdad
se mantiene igual porque el 4 es un
número positivo y después me queda 4
entre 2 es 2 2 por 5 o 10 entonces 8 r
menos 13 tiene que ser menor que 10
porque 2 por 5 10 bueno primero déjenme
resolver esta desigualdad del lado
izquierdo y ya después de 9 con la
desigualdad del lado derecho de aquí si
lo que quiero es despejar aire lo
primero que voy a hacer es sumar 13 de
ambos lados de la ecuación y me queda
que 8 r tiene que ser menor estos dos se
van que 10 más 13 que es 23 y bueno si
divido a ambos lados de esta desigualdad
entre 8 y como ochos número positivos se
conserva la desigualdad me queda que 8 y
8 se van la desigualdad se mantiene
igual y entonces me queda que r tiene
que ser menor que 23 octavos r tiene que
ser menor que 23
perfecto ya que tengo mi solución de mi
primera desigualdad r menor que 23
octavos o esto si lo vemos como fracción
mixta es dos enteros siete octavos 8 por
2 16 más 7 23 bueno pero está en una
primera parte en una primera desigualdad
porque también tengo otra desigualdad
dice se tiene que cumplir la primera
desigualdad y la segunda desigualdad que
es esta que tengo aquí pero de igual
manera tengo fracciones por lo tanto lo
primero que voy a hacer es multiplicar
ambos lados de esta desigualdad por 4
otra vez como en 4 es un número positivo
no se afecte a desigualdad y me queda 8
r menos 13 tiene que ser mayor que 4
entre 2 es 2 x 5 es 10 menos 10 8 r
menos 3 y tiene que ser mayor que menos
10 y sumando 13 damos lado de la
ecuación nos va a quedar que 8 r13 menos
tres se van 8 r tiene que ser mayor que
menos 10 más 13 que es 38 r tiene que
ser mayor que 3 y bueno yo lo que quiero
es despejar a r de esta desigualdad por
lo tanto voy a dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 8 como ocho su número
positivo no se afecta esta desigualdad
me queda que r es mayor que tres octavos
ya tres octavos no le podemos sacar
enteros por lo tanto es una fracción
propia y perfecto ya tenemos entonces
mis dos condiciones que tienen que
cumplir y por lo tanto mi intervalo en
el cual vive r r por una parte tiene que
ser mayor que tres octavos para que
cumpla esta desigualdad con valor
absoluto r tiene que ser mayor que tres
octavos y por otra parte tiene que ser
menor que dos enteros siete octavos así
que pues lo único que nos falta es
ponerlo en esta recta numérica y vamos a
ver qué tal nos queda cero por aquí va a
estar el uno por aquí va a estar el dos
y por aquí vamos a tener el tres y yo lo
que quiero es que sea en primer lugar
más chico que dos enteros siete octavos
dos centros y está octavo está por aquí
y después que sea más grande que tres
octavos voy a decir que tres octavos
está por aquí y bueno como son
desigualdades estrictas entonces no
tocan tres octavos no tocan dos entre
los siete octavos y todo lo que vivan
aquí en medio de estos dos va a ser mi
solución y bueno sería bastante útil
probar que realmente si es esta solución
si no me tengo un número
aquí entre estos dos supongamos uno
vamos a ver qué me queda con esta
desigualdad dos por uno porque vale uno
menos
enteros 14 2 - 3 enteros 1 4 y esto es
lo mismo que 3 enteros 14 menos 2 es un
entero un cuarto por menos me quedan
menos un entero un cuarto pero ojo me
estoy tomando el valor absoluto el valor
absoluto de esto el valor absoluto de
esto el valor absoluto de esto y esto es
igual a un entero un cuarto que por
cierto es mucho más pequeño que dos
enteros un medio y qué pasa si me tomo
un valor que esté fuera de este
intervalo será que me equivoqué y tal
vez esté en esta solución pues vamos a
ver si vale cero no queda 2 x 0 0 - 3
enteros 14 el valor absoluto de menos 3
enteros 14 es 3 enteros un cuarto y
lamentablemente no es parte de un
solución porque esto es más grande que
dos enteros un medio y supongamos que me
toma ahora 3 vamos a ver si con el 3
funciona dos por tres es 66 menos tres
enteros un cuarto es dos enteros tres
cuartos dos enteros tres cuartos lo cual
cuando me tomo el valor absoluto de
estos entre los tres cuartos que es
mayor que dos enteros un medio es una
lástima porque por lo tanto no está en
nuestra solución